Matthew Perry's fans were left deeply
saddened by his final Instagram post
which was published only days before his
tragic death at the age of 54 it has
also left some wondering if there was a
hidden meaning behind it Matthew Perry's
sudden death on October 28th 2023 came
as a shock to his millions of fans the
Beloved performer was discovered after
apparently drowning in his own hot tub
Perry leaves a long Legacy of work
behind him even outside his iconic role
as a sarcastic channel of being onf
friend the actor has been Frank about
having substance abuse issues in the
past and spoke about them in his 2022
Memoir friends lovers and the big
terrible thing it's not currently known
whether they played a role in his
drowning still as we tried to make sense
of his death his final Instagram post
has taken on an ominous new tone on
October 22nd 2023 Perry posted a picture
of himself lounging in his sizable hotb
with his headphones on the caption in
the post reads oh so warm water swirling
around makes you feel feel good I'm
Matman the last bit is a reference to
Perry's love of Batman something that is
clearly noticeable in his other posts on
Instagram I got a gift uh of a Batman a
statue of Batman that's about that high
these posts include the actor watching
the Batman on several big screen TVs and
a Halloween pumpkin car with a hero's
symbol on it given the many comments on
Perry's final Instagram post it was
clear that his fans were shaken by his
untimely death hundreds of comments
Mourns the actor's passing and they
showed just how Beloved the friend's
performer really was in case some
massive sales of his Memoir didn't make
that obvious enough one Instagram user
wrote in the comments you won't even
understand the love that everyone will
always have for you this may be the one
where we lost a friend to everyone but
this is the one where I hope you are at
peace this has become the prevailing
sentiment on the actor's last Instagram
post as tributes continue pouring in
other fans took on the colorful dry wit
of Chan Le Bing to honor the actor
another Instagram user wrote my
connection to you started when we shook
hands at an AA meeting I was Star Struck
you were kind and humble see you on the
other side my friend could I be any more
sad right now however some fans are now
arguing over whether or not Perry's
final post had a hidden meaning for
instance some of his fans took the final
post as a confession of sorts as
demonstrated by the comments however
many of his most Ardent supporters found
the insinuation to be distasteful that
said the top comment on Perry's final
post as commenters to be a little more
respectful and sensitive with regard to
the Stars passing the comment read I
would like to point out to everyone who
is assuming things to go read his bloody
book Matthew used to go in his hot tub
every night and look at the lights and
stars be grateful that he made it that
far in a world where people are still
discussing conspiracy theories regarding
the deaths of Tupac Shakur Kurt Cain and
even John F Kennedy it seems unlikely
that even the most reasoned arguments
will put this kind of conjecture to an
end still given the vast scope of his
work drawing and after friends fans
don't need to remember Perry for how he
died instead they can recall The
Talented performer for all the smiles
and laughter he gave to the
[Music]
world